sweet anita is a popular twitch variety
streamer with over 1.7 million followers
and while she does have a positive fan
base supporting her she's also spoken
out about the abuse stalking and threats
she's received from some of the people
that watch her she's discovered an
entire reddit community dedicated to
sexualizing otherwise innocuous images
and videos of her she's even had a
stalker sleep outside of her house and
assault her for anita she's found many
good things in her streaming career to
date but the darker side has been
undeniable and prevalent for most of her
time on twitch
sweet anita is an english streamer who
began her twitch career in 2018 and
quickly grew in popularity thanks to her
gaming content and openness about being
a streamer with tourette's syndrome in
fact it's this unique combination of
gaming and involuntary ticks that have
helped endear fans to anita over the
years
thanks there's easier ways to say you're
the other imposter just tell us you're
the other impossible
thank you for believing me guys
the score esports spoke to anita back in
2019 and anita explained that she can
see both the funny side and also the
difficulties that she's faced from her
conditions yeah totally fine i'm a tiny
little woman screaming at the top of my
lungs about a dick i clearly don't have
of course that's ridiculous of course
that's funny i know it's ridiculous and
i'm perfectly fine with other people
seeing it that way too um and to be
honest i grew up being treated quite
harshly for my condition and with no
diagnosis and no way to explain what was
going on people treated me as if those
actions were intentional and that was
really hard and really scary but her
candid accounts about her experiences
with tourette's syndrome have offered an
educational window to thousands online
who might be unfamiliar with or
misinformed about the condition so my
stereotype of tourette syndrome was that
it was only swear words that you always
shouted them that it couldn't ever be
complex and the things that i was doing
when i was alone
were complex sometimes i'd sit there and
i just go i killed 52 000 men and that
doesn't seem to fit with the idea of
someone just shouting one random word
over and over there were certain
situations where it didn't happen and i
didn't know why when i interact with
animals when i'm caring for someone i
don't take as much when i whistle i
don't tick at all and when i
you know when i
focus and fixate on something without
distraction the ticks go away if you
tune into a need to stream on any given
day you're usually met with gaming
chatting with her viewers or reactions
to videos by any measure anita has a
popular variety stream where she and her
viewers just have fun but anita also
hasn't shied away from talking about the
negative experiences she's had from
streaming on twitch every stream has its
share of unwanted viewers but many
streamers have to deal with something
far worse than your average troll there
are those who watch her stream who only
bring harm people who have sexualized
her against her will threatened her and
even stalked her sometimes in real life
in an interview with the huffington post
anita talked about stumbling upon a
subreddit which stated it contained not
safe for work pictures of her she was
naturally confused because she'd of
course never streamed without clothes on
most of these images and videos have
been taken from anita's stream at
seemingly innocent moments her getting
up from a chair or walking away from the
camera but these people had screenshot
at the moments where they could see any
part of her body and share them with
each other in a sexually suggestive
manner some had even manipulated the
images to make her clothes appear
transparent or had photoshopped her into
pornography and this online behavior has
also spilled out into the real world in
2019 she talked openly about a stalker
who had spent hours outside of her house
and had assaulted her before being
caught and detained by the police the
other day sir some shopkeepers had to
intervene and kind of hold him back
while he chased after me
um because he waited outside my house
followed me into a shop then waited for
me outside the shop and
when i told him to leave me alone and
asked if he had a knife he didn't
respond
and when i said are you gonna let me
walk home alone he said yes and then
when i went across the road he started
chasing and two guys ran out of the shop
and grabbed him and then grabbed hold of
the gate to
um
another area of town and i so i went
through the gate and they held it closed
so that he couldn't pass them and
continue to follow me
it's not the worst thing he's done he
has actually physically assaulted me
over the years anita has talked multiple
times on her stream and on social media
about a stalker who's threatened her
with violence online tracked her down in
real life and physically assaulted her
and this situation isn't just isolated
to anita here there's a pattern of
behavior other streamers such as bx
bullet have discussed twitch's stalking
problem they went over there to talk to
him about it i guess and
according to him and he could be lying
um or bluffing but he said that they
told him that somebody in texas had
you know tipped them off so
after that he just came at me with
everything he had and he's been coming
at me with everything he has with doxing
harassment bots
threats uh tell him you know telling me
he has my address and like
saying things like see you soon or can't
wait to come visit you kind of stuff i
spoke to anita who told me that far from
this being a recent thing the unwanted
sexualization and abuse she's received
has been happening for as long as she's
been on twitch oh well it's not
particularly recent it's just been the
whole time that i've been streaming i've
always had people
be sexual be
push boundaries and be cruel and
sometimes it's from the angle that you
know people are like well i used to find
you attractive but now you've gained
weight so you've disappointed me and i'm
unsubbing and then there are people who
are just like
um
one day i will find you and i will rape
you like this it's so extreme and
often very just
i don't know very intentionally cruel it
doesn't seem like people who are just
like besotted and hopelessly in love and
i feel like whenever i talk about it
people get upset with me for complaining
because they picture that i have all of
these nerdy boys that are hopelessly in
love with me and i should be grateful
for the attention is the overall
response that i get anita told me that
she's often been subjected to unfair
accusations of playing the victim card
that speaking out about it has often
been met with overwhelming disgust and
distrust despite this she said she has
intermittently spoken up about the
behavior either to the perpetrator
themself or to a wider audience on the
matter for most people watching this
twitch is just entertainment a screen
where you can go and watch your favorite
content creators at any hour of the day
but it's sometimes easy to forget that
for full-time streamers this isn't just
a place they dip in and out of purely
for fun in many cases this is their
full-time job their stream is their
workplace just like any other workplace
but for whatever reason streamers aren't
offered the same workplace protections
and expectations that many of us take
for granted in our own lives if you were
experiencing this level of abuse in any
other job people would say quit people
would say sue people would say this is
horrible but if you are a content
creator it's expected that you should be
willing to and able to
endure this level of harassment every
single day and the worst part is there's
no way to tell which one of these people
is going to take it off the stream and
into the real world because plenty of
people have
um with me specifically and with other
content creators too
um so there's no way to know if this is
like just someone messing around and
being rude or someone who's going to
wait in your back garden with a knife
which is something that's happened when
it comes to abuse and streamer safety
twitch has a page on their creator camp
where they discuss the moderation and
safeguard tools that streamers can use
these tools are supposed to give
creators the confidence that quote when
they stream on twitch it will be a
positive experience adding that they
take the responsibility seriously as
part of their mission to make everyone
feel welcome and protected these tools
include auto mods chat rules moderators
timeouts and bands but the most these
tools can do is to allow a streamer to
deal with one account not the actual
person behind that account you can have
moderators who can remove people who are
being overtly sexual or being cruel but
the problem with this is they can just
make a new account and do it over and
over again and there are so many and
there is always a new person doing it so
it doesn't really stop even if you ban
each individual one you're still going
to see it hundreds of times
a day and these judgments are really
broad and really cruel and sometimes
threatening um
so it's it's one of those things where
you have to be able to be the kind of
person who can read those things and see
those things
every single day for hours non-stop and
pretend it's not happening and still
smile and still laugh and still be
entertaining and that's one of the
reasons why it's harder to be a woman on
any content creation platform because in
general
men usually don't have to face this type
of harassment on top of the typical kind
that all streamers get and this is a
great point people's natural reaction
when abuse or sexual harassment happens
on a platform is that it's the
platform's responsibility to stamp it
out and this is true to an extent twitch
said they had a responsibility to make
their platform safe but to add to that
in my conversation with anita she talked
about the problem going beyond any
individual platform so there's no
specific platform online where i would
point them and go you're failing us
because it's it's it's a universal
problem that applies to anything online
um so yeah i don't hold the platforms
responsible i i feel like it's the law
um and i know this because stalking
victims in general get no justice
usually if you're being stalked
nothing's gonna happen many people get
murdered by the person they've been
stopped by who they've reported to the
police multiple times like the thing
with it is is that you're powerless and
there's no change to be had unless
there's punishments for behaving this
way if you sexually harass anyone and
any other workplace
there can be prison there could be fines
there can be justice
but this isn't possible here until the
law catches up
of course it's really important to note
here that it's not the responsibility of
streamers like anita to propose a legal
fix for these problems just as it's not
the responsibility for a victim of any
other kind of abuse this is clearly a
wider issue that can't just be fixed
with banned buttons and timeouts it
happens on many many platforms and the
internet at large perhaps the bare
minimum that can be done here is to
listen to people like anita hear their
stories and create a wider awareness of
the abuse threats and stalking that they
receive when they step into their online
workplace and while these issues are
deeply concerning to many people anita
was clear with me that she speaks up
with a sense of hopefulness that she has
good intentions which shouldn't be met
with anger it's still a really fun place
to be there's still amazing people here
um
but like
i i critique it hopefully it's it's an a
form of optimism that makes me speak up
um but yeah you often get backed into a
corner and then it becomes all you are
to people the only time they ever hear
from you or see your content and being
promoted it's when you're supposedly
complaining about men is how it's
perceived and then that hurts you as a
content creator because it's not fun
it's not really promotion it makes
people really defensive and it generally
just makes gamers angry at you
so even though i'm doing it with good
intentions wanting you know people to
mingle more wanting more women in gaming
wanting it to be safer and happier i'm
being treated like i'm exploiting
someone lying about someone exaggerating
things and it's just i would love an
opportunity for this to be a discussion
that's beneficial for everyone involved
rather than it being a sacrifice that
women have to take on because
essentially that means that we're taking
responsibility for these people's
behavior they don't get any negative
consequences they just get a ban they
make a new account it continues
for us it hurts our view account it
hurts our wages it hurts our reputation
it hurts people's view of us and it's
stressful and
exhausting um and so i just wish yeah
that it wasn't us who bear the burden of
these people's bad behavior anymore
[Music]
you